in Florida last night Donald Trump
announced that he is running for
president again if you've been following
his rallies that he has done around the
country for the last couple of years
some of it seemed familiar but there
were parts of the speech where he
offered solutions to problems that you
haven't heard before and that nobody
seems to be talking about at least in
the way that he spoke about last night
the fentanyl crisis for example he
offered a plan to fix it he said he
would wage war on the Mexican drug
cartels and Institute the death penalty
for people who deal fentanyl
we will wage war upon the cartels and
stop the Fentanyl and deadly drugs from
killing two hundred thousand Americans
per year
and I will ask Congress for legislation
ensuring that drug dealers and human
traffickers these are terrible terrible
horrible people who are responsible for
death Carnage and crime all over our
country every drug dealer during his or
her life on average will kill 500 people
with the drugs they sell not to mention
the destruction of families
but we're going to be asking everyone
who sells drugs gets caught selling
drugs to receive the death penalty for
their heinous acts
now that's interesting idea you may like
it you may not like it by the way you
may like Trump you may not like Trump
you could be a Democrat who lives to
despise him you could be a republican
who prefers Ron DeSantis there are many
of both of those categories maybe
someone who love him it doesn't really
matter what you think of trump or his
policies on fennel or anything else if
you're an American you have to
acknowledge that in order for our
democracy to function candidates for
office political candidates have to be
allowed to speak in public if they can't
speak in public this can't be a
democracy by definition
and yet here you have Twitter Banning
Trump he's still banned despite Elon
musk's takeover Trump is still banned
from Twitter tonight one of our premier
social media platforms parlor you'll
remember was pulled off the internet for
giving Donald Trump an account
now at the time people read those as
offenses against Trump were sick of
trump make him shut up
but they're more than that they're
attacks on our system their attacks on
Democracy their attacks on the
possibility of a free Society
so you have to wonder now
where are the Defenders of democracy
people were yelling last week about
democracy's dying if they're not calling
for Trump to be re-platformed you'll
know for certain they're not Defenders
of democracy they're totalitarians
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight